[Music]
let you meet these young people these
are my freshman class this is a good
group
my associate advisor Sharma you can go
ahead and tell them no and then just go
around tell her what you're doing any
where are you from I was that interested
in them
[Music]
and you are a freshman yeah so you don't
have to really decide at this point
my name is talk with you know Alabama
you know how did I know that lying about
your course six my name is juice bar
from Largo Massachusetts where it is I
don't know
oh okay and I am a tree very good what
part of Kenya
questions join us on the trees and some
wailing maps and
doesn't matter I think really one of the
hidden treasures of MIT is the freshman
curriculum you may not feel that now but
you know I think other universities
would really give their eyeteeth to have
all the freshmen studying the same thing
more or less but you can talk to one
another and don't have this feeling of
and so critical forces they don't
understand you do but know that's there
I mean it gives you a whole year to
decide what you want to do and at the
same time you're making important
academic progress okay just one I do
yeah they just watch the distillation oh
sure been there done that that's right
and what I'd like you to do is reflect
upon your as whereas here is a woman to
then my team what does win like and or
all of the whole group I'm interested in
you talking and they're asking questions
and getting a sense of this place from a
particular perspective the one thing
you've heard a little bit is would your
perception be the same that they were
talking about the experience they went
over and how the numbers after by modal
distribution after they got a certain
critical mass that that disappeared just
straight out well I was like who taught
that seminar what is engineering with no
address no house I think that was an
exciting experiment was interesting on
my good friend norm on Steam who
recently retired as the CEO of Lockheed
Martin went to Princeton to teach and I
asked him I said what are you going to
teach he said well he said I think I'll
offer a freshman seminar called what is
engineering I said great idea let me
give you some advice but you know it was
a lot of fun we really enjoyed it and
you know I think it didn't have a big
impact
let me back up just a little bit cuz I
can do this kind of personal
retrospective because I was there I came
to MIT as a freshman in 1956 and I'm
from Tacoma Washington and I only began
to realize how strong those those
influences were two things about coming
from Tacoma I think were important one
is that my family's home was on the
final approach to McChord Air Force Base
so the sky was literally always full of
planes the second thing is that the
larger largest employer in the northwest
is boring aircraft and so I think it
didn't take me too long to figure out
and although I didn't commit myself when
I was a freshman but by the end of my
freshman year I knew I wanted to major
in aeronautical engineering and I think
that there a lot of that had to do with
making Tacoma and having every
anticipation of returning to the
northwest working for Boeing and
designing airplanes why did you come
here well I had been involved in the
local science yard when the local
science fair I was recruited by a very
active MIT educational counselor I have
to say I was more actively recruited by
MIT than any other school University of
Chicago said well why should we give you
a scholarship you'll just get married
and won't work well I was absolutely
insulted by that remark and you know
Stanford Caltech didn't take women
Stanford you know it was just
non-committal in the sense you know you
send in your application they'll let you
know MIT was fiercely aggressively
recruiting we had a whole bunch of
freshmen coming from Seattle I had a
total group of 20 we had a meeting in
Seattle with all the incoming students
and the alumni from Seattle
they picked me as a result of this very
energetic guy from Tacoma to give their
sort of central scholarship to so I was
very well treated by MIT I was very well
treated by this yet all along and you
know I really felt that I was coming to
a place that was really anxious to have
me and you know that's always a turn-on
so that's why I came to MIT I really
didn't know anything about the East
didn't particularly like it and vowed
never to stay here
well so much for two out of three ain't
bad but the thing of surprising when I
arrived at MIT was sitting around the
freshman or the women's dorm in those
days there were only 20 of us who had
made this decision out of all the women
in the United States they're only 20
women who decided to come near my feet I
found it a little startling I hadn't
thought much about it but I'd realized
the numbers would be so small I guess I
made a fundamental decision at that
point that if I was going to worry about
that that I was not going to graduate so
I basically just sort of plowed through
without asking myself the question you
know was this a good place for women to
why aren't there more women why was I
here you know which people used to ask
me all the time I said I'll get back to
you later
so I didn't worry about it I just sort
of applied right through and was very
successful I could done nothing I did
take a little while to spin up I mean my
first semester at MIT we had grades in
those days per semester at MIT where my
most measures was was successful but I
basically got to be in everything so I
got to be average and that put me on
what was then the Dean's List but it was
not a spectacular performance but then
it was sort of going up after that and I
actually had a couple of semesters where
I got you know the coveted final
but I had a bita marvelous time I mean
the arrow Department was a great
department it's very very faculty
student oriented I mean you know I had
faculty you just were tremendously
supportive whole Bassianus my advisor
and halt took the place of the guy from
Tacoma hmm you know was my champion my
mentor was always putting me forward for
awards and everything like that and as I
think about it throughout my life I
think I have accumulated about 10 or 12
what I would view as mentors people who
have really taken it upon themselves to
be my sponsor and I guess I draw an
important lesson from that that all of
you will have people like that and you
will also be people like that you having
been sponsored and mentored by somebody
will then have a responsibility to do
the same for other people but needless
to say I never did leave MIT I stayed
here and I am part of this whole history
that's referred to on the videotape
I saw MIT and didn't sit by and watch
but was an active participant in MIT
going from basically 1% women to 43% man
there are a lot of watersheds in that in
that activity that building the women's
dorm the sort of changing from
admissions being limited by housing to
we know more or less open admissions the
extremely important studies that Art
Smith did during
remember when that was the mid 70s or
late 70s or middle 80s or whatever it
was that basically showed statistically
that the math SAT score is under
predictive performance of women relative
to their their senior accomplishments
and so if your goal is to graduate a
class of seniors rather than admit a
class of freshmen then you should use
that information and then whitey began
to do that and in one year went from 26
percent to 38 percent women and it was a
success the women's grade point average
which is not the only measure of
greatness but quick point average
general success basically remained equal
or better than that of the men so so
this bold experiment worked and I don't
think any other university in the nation
is this conscious of what that really
means I mean first of all I don't think
MIT is publicized that we've kept it we
haven't even told the students which of
course is created no ender problem but
you know we haven't we've been kind of
quiet about it
we know something that our the
universities don't really know and we
just haven't you know I think been as
forthcoming and sharing well it is and I
actually am a good friend of the
president of Caltech and his wife Alice
and she's a you know major figure in
biology and actually we spent weekend
together about a month ago more or less
and they would really like to understand
how they can reshape their admissions
process to have the kind of achievement
that MIT has had so I promise to send
her the data and I promise
she could figure out because I think MIT
really understands what it's doing this
respect to the admissions we see the
result of that all around us in
character threshold classic character
the senior class and the accomplishments
of male and female students across the
Institute it's a very different place
even going down leaving the place for
four years and coming back it's a very
different place as I come back even my
own department is different my own
department when I left I was the only
woman on faculty in the Aero Department
roughly speaking I think dogging me was
just coming in at that point now at this
point I can't even count the number
women in the faculty and certainly if I
if I include the senior research staff
sort of principal scientists people who
teach and do research it's probably 10
probably 10 people in my apartment and
it's not unusual to go to a meeting of
our project and find virtually the
entire room full of women I happen to be
working on a project called the lean
aerospace initiative which deals with
the streamlining and downsizing in the
defense industry an industrial
efficiency and acquisition reform and
getting you know equipment faster better
cheaper and using more commercial
practices so as I said we got an
exciting project and a substantial
fraction of our team are senior women
scientists as well as women graduate
students and water women graduate
students soon in the project so MIT is a
very different place and ultimately I
think mi t--'s didn't really set it on
the tape mi t--'s big contribution will
be in its students and students that it
trains you give our students the tools
and the and the attitudes and the
technique they need for success not only
in a technical sense with their
leadership sense so
it's gonna be a good place for me this
means that you all are here because you
reaffirmed what was it like though going
through that undergraduate well first of
all you know - so I tell them this
first of all MIT is a big intellectual
jump maybe not as much he really is high
schools have improved so for many
students it's not as much of an
intellectual jump as it was for me when
I came I came from a parochial high
school all-girls school Catholic school
we didn't have physics I had to get on
the bus every afternoon and go down to
the public high school to take physics
you recall that the faculty passed what
I turned witness revenge when I was
chairman of the faculty we passed a rule
that says physics is not an absolute
requirement for admission to MIT
although one person here yeah right well
you know you're all that to me because
in my daily bus trips down to to take
physics at their local high school
anyway I know most people do take
physics but and I came him with physics
but you know obviously in those days I
think quality the high schools for a
place like MIT was just you know it was
a whole different thing and so I think
the initial shock was really like you
know taking a bath and ice water and I
failed my first physics test
I got a thirty many people also fail
their first physics test but that for me
was a kind of a wake-up a kind of one of
these defining moments because that
certainly the experience of sitting in
that test and realizing that I didn't
that I was not on the same wavelength as
the faculty and then reflecting on that
after which I had about two hours to do
maybe you realize why MIT was really
expecting that it wasn't a matter of
feeding back what you heard
it was a matter of creating something
new you know solving a problem you had
never seen before and somehow I
understood that and I said okay so I
understand I understand what is expected
and from then on I think I had a
completely different appreciation of
what MIT wasn't and what the expectation
was and having figured it out
proceeded to kind of charge ahead I had
a fairly disciplined approach to MIT I
never pulled an all-nighter I never
stayed up all night I never did I've
being a fluid dynamicists I know that
time is incompressible what you want to
do is put yourself in a position where
you're maximizing total system
efficiency which means the physical the
mental you know the psychological all of
that you've got you know you got it get
yourself in a situation where you're
maximizing total system efficiency and I
don't you know I mean maybe if you get
an emergency once in a while but I mean
on as a regular basis you've got to take
care of yourself you've just got to keep
keep yourself so that you can perform
and their various ways to do that
not well
I would say in general not well we had
some very unfortunate things happen
first of all we we had more women come
than MIT had planned for so they put the
torch thing I was not one of the women
but they put half of the women in a
temporary living situation over on it
was Marlborough Street they ran her to
brown stone they put them over there
they put me and a bunch of others in the
women's dorm in about November I think
the landlady decided that the girls
weren't keeping their rooms clean and
she literally threw them out on the
street
she took their belongings and put them
out on the street well I might he had to
do a little ketchup ball and it put it
found temporary accommodations for many
of those women's students in the BU
dorms but the study conditions are not
adequate we view women students at MIT
where the students don't have that much
in common
students lucked out I mean it was
including my very best friend I mean I
had a friend who was put in that
situation and she flunked out so you
know it's it's not a happy story I think
it was probably that it's in as much as
any that convinced MIT that it that it
was going to have women students had to
do it right and I think that was one of
the motivations for basically going over
was a famous story
Kilian Stratton get in a cab and go over
to see mrs. MacCormack and talk her into
you know building a women's dorm first
little did we know that co-ed dorms
would soon you know you know we didn't
see that we didn't know that was coming
so you know the housing problem
ultimately solved itself in lots of
different ways but the initial step in
that was where's the women's dorm
so no MIT was a very demanding place and
a lot of a lot of people you know had
difficulty with it so you took your
degree here and then I stayed and I
stayed and I stayed and I stay I've only
been away from MIT for two periods in
Washington I went down in 1974 where I
served as the director of university
research for the Department of
Transportation and that was another one
of these mentor things I had a choir
mentor along the way just even was a
touching go mentor I didn't really you
know because he was actually the he was
Bob cannon actually used to be a non
mechanical engineer partner I met him
several times he was then the assistant
secretary at the Department of
Transportation and asked me to come come
down and in run this program and just
before I got there he left to become
Dean of engineering at Cal Tech and he
called me from his cellular phone on the
way out of Washington saying well I have
a good time I just want you to know that
I won't be here it's probably the best
thing that ever happened to me
you know cuz then I was totally
independent I didn't have somebody to
take care of me I had to do everything
myself so it was a real learning
experience and of course obviously the
other time was was going down to
Washington and being Secretary of the
Air Force which show was true truly
incredible experience really incredible
experience what's good to that another
mentor relationship yeah well that's
right how does that each other in this
that's right you just have to work very
hard you know I would never you know
minimize the difficulty of basically
having it all
I mean I think I think it takes a lot of
work takes a lot of organization and and
it's taking on a lot of responsibilities
but I see more and more people doing it
I think the world has changed and rather
dramatic ways I think I see you know
many more dual-career couples you know
making things happen it even affects us
in the Air Force I mean one of the
reasons I think the Air Force is having
a pilot retention problem is that the
expectations have changed it is no
longer the expectation that you know the
guy will go off and fly in Saudi Arabia
and that the rest of the family will
just sit there and wait they're not
content to sit there and wait and he's
not content to do that either he wants
to be with his family so I think that
what I see happening and all over the
country is that there's a real change
that there's a sharing there's more of
an equal partnership and the Air Force
has got some major challenges figuring
out how to accommodate these really new
realities and families and the way
people want to have a family want to be
together want to share responsibilities
that's not just an issue for people at
MIT it's an issue for everybody all over
the country and it's a major change in
the way we think about our
responsibilities and so yeah I think I
think it'll get easier
I think it'll get easier because it's
it's just you know much more much more
the expectation that people have you
know for richer lives and there'll be a
lot more sharing nobody talks about it
the conversations we've had about how
this place was not very sensitive to the
needs of woman to the children and
scheduling how in fact she tells some
stories in our conversations about
another woman who came on the fact that
their cameras research that she did and
like your friend just simply couldn't
make it and trying to do I never had any
I never had any special favors I mean I
don't know how to say this exactly I
mean I was always a tomboy I mean you
come into my office and you see my
picture of me and my flight seat and
everything like that I only stayed away
for two weeks when I had my children I
just was full steam ahead I didn't you
know expect any any accommodation and I
never asked for it bill of course my
husband bill was enormous ly helpful I
mean we are you know probably more like
today's young people are than our
contemporaries although I have to say
you know that I really notice a big
change between the class of 60 and the
class of 59 at MIT I go to both reunions
because my husband's in 59 and I'm in 60
and 60 the class of 60 is much more I
don't know how to say it committed to
equality they accept women as full and
equal participants in in their lives in
their work and whatever they do class 59
is just a little conservative I find
them just a little because they were you
know the the number of women in that
class was very very different they
weren't as mainstream I think there's a
women in the class of 60 and then I
think from then on I think there was a
change
I think there was a change and I think I
see that reflected in the Alumni
Association people who went to MIT of
these different times so I really
believe there was a watershed between
to 1960 yeah in what was going on at MIT
and it wasn't you know just me I mean
that we had a Linda Greiner then the
Greiner was editor of the attack so we
have many women students who you know in
very substantial leadership positions so
the whole the whole climate I think for
women students at MIT change during
during those times well these these are
cultural issues there's no question
about it but I have very unusual family
first of all I was the oldest girl of a
family of girls and I think if you look
back statistically at families like that
you will find that the oldest girl is
often the surrogate son I mean that just
happens so so I was absolutely
encouraged and everything I did also my
mother was another real pioneer my
mother worked she worked all the time I
was growing up she quit work to be at
home with me when I was starting to
school and I she drove me crazy and I
said mother for heaven's sakes go back
to work so my mother was a social worker
during the Depression she she managed
cases of people who are on welfare and
then after she went back to work when I
threw out the house she became a
juvenile probation officer so she you
know a very active career and she worked
with families that were disintegrating
kids that were in trouble either
because their families are
disintegrating or because
come delinquent so so she worked the
whole time that I was so my models my
models were of you know women who
basically combined career and family and
my father was you know very interesting
he did all sorts of different things but
he he was a rodeo cowboy when he met my
mother so I mean just strong family very
strong family very supportive yes yes it
is unusual great guy miss him so much
passed away just before everything
second you put so he never knew yeah I
love I love it guy he was just my first
mentor wonderful man very supportive we
build things together that's really why
I'm an engineer daddy and I built things
I was 21 years old before I realized you
could hire people to come to your house
to fix things I mean we always we not
only fix things in our house we fix
things in the neighbor's house yeah one
of the new neighbors came over knocked
on the door and and said can Raleigh
come over and fix my sink and my mother
was taken aback says he doesn't do
things like that mm-hmm well mr. Brayman
said that he was the kind fixed
everything in the neighborhood so anyway
that's why I'm an engineer probably as
much as anything this at you know
hands-on hands-on experience
hi Stephanie you got me
no that's fine go ahead guys don't lose
this moment yeah come on questions don't
be shy women should speak up ah well
first of all I went to a girls school so
I think I think women who go to girls
schools are often more independent than
women that go to sort of co-educational
high schools
I think that's statistically true I
think that I my friends were a very
independent bunch of girls and you know
I think you know most of them did go to
college some ways most of them stayed
pretty close to Washington I was clearly
the The Outlaw outlier but I think
people are very supportive of their
their daughters
well you know MIT is very layered I mean
there's the faculty there's your fellow
students there's the upperclassmen I
mean it's it's probably impossible to
general generalize I think my department
was very supportive so if I could make
it through my freshman year and get to
my sophomore year I found a group of
faculty who were extremely supportive
very anxious to have me here I think in
my freshman year well actually there was
there were some faculty members who
really went out of their way to be
supportive I remember in particular than
my math professor professor Douglas
whose name is one of those hallowed
names around MIT who really was very
supportive I mean I still remember
taking a quiz in 1801 and having him use
this great old grandfather magani judge
me says I got to get you a Coke or
something you know he just you know I
didn't really need a coke but I just
thought that that he was just
tremendously supportive so he was was
really good and that's a good feeling to
have about an instructor because you
know they can be a little terrifying but
you know when when they're approachable
like that so yeah I would say that there
were a few people who were you know
really approachable and and incidentally
you know I took 1802 from Professor
Maddock who I understand is still
teaching H know - but not I found the
faculty either didn't pay any attention
to me at all or we're supportive and I
think it was particularly true in the
Aero department I had some really strong
supporters you know that that saw I said
I guess that's it it was either being
ignored which was not bad for student or
being supported so that's that and with
my classmates they come in all shapes
and sizes
I think I I was asked a lot you know
what are you doing here
I chose not to worry about that issue
but I used to go out a lot too so I mean
you know it's one of the advantages
being only 1% more dates and my
husband's still kidding me about all the
all the guys I flunked out because that
you know I could handle the
extracurricular stuff better than they
could so this was for you the home you
needed to find I think so I think of MIT
as my home I mean I've been here more of
my life than I've been I've been in
Tacoma and I think I've really made
contributions to this community I was
chairman of the faculty I was chairman
of the admissions committee I was
chairman of the discipline committee I
served in a lot of important roles on
the faculty and certainly served as a
policymaker in issues having to do with
with women students initiative women
students so there are people who think
that you know you might even send a be
the first of all impress in this place
I think I'm a little too old where I'll
think about that maybe but that's around
what about the air force how did you
find that experience I mean was that
just my tear it large Oh No yeah no idea
was it was different
let's see it's hard to describe how I
got there I mean that was basically
another relationship another mentor
relationship I had been on the board of
the Carnegie Corporation and David
hamburger is the president the Carnegie
Corporation and he was one of my really
important mentors and Warren Christopher
who became Secretary of State was the
chairman of that board and Warren Chris
was doing a lot to construct the
administration and I was sitting in the
office over in the Provost's office
there where I was and David Hamburg
called me up and he said Sheila he said
I've got an absolutely great idea and I
called up senator Nunn and and mr. Aspen
who was about to become secretary
difensa they think it's a great idea too
he said I think you should be Secretary
of the Air Force I said David I said
that is an absolutely super idea so you
know after that it just all kind of fell
into place you know in well I'd always
wanted to be secretary here no I never
mentioned it to anybody but you know I
had boss I mean I had known at least
half of the previous Secretary of the
Air Force they had been aeronautical
engineers Bob seaman's was even a member
of our department but I'd served on the
aerospace board or Peter Aldridge was a
former secretary I knew John McLucas and
and Joe Charak and you know just Don
Rice and you know I'd know a lot of the
previous secretaries of the Air Force
and they had backgrounds that were not
unlike mine and so it's actually a job
I've always wanted so I thought it was a
terrific job and you know I really liked
it it's a very complicated organ
it's a budget of you know roughly sixty
billion dollars and you know four
hundred thousand active duty and another
two hundred thousand Reserve and you
know roughly 175 thousand civilian
full-time employees plus you know the
Pentagon which is like no place that
I've ever been and you know the
relationships between the political and
side and the military side and and
policymaking and it's just a it's just a
very complicated environment it's not
unlike MIT in the sense that in order to
get something done you have to build
consensus I think that people from
industry going into that situation often
have a hard time as people from industry
often think that all you have to do is
give an order and something happens it's
not the way Washington works right so I
do think actively academics do very well
in that environment because there's a
lot of consultation there's a lot of
sort of building consensus I think the
intellectual issues are very important
and you have to be able to work with
large groups of people and and you know
kind of get all the ideas and get it
sort of framed and get it sort of down
to some consensus so a lot of the tools
that I learned at MIT were extremely
useful and I think it dealing with the
people I actually think my background as
an educator was more useful than my
background as an engineer because I mean
in the end it really is about people and
I think people who are in education
focus on people you focus on career
development one of the big things I did
in the Air Force that I'm probably the
most proud of is is core values we
basically articulated and and stress the
core values of the Air Force and an
institution like MIT is about core
values too
in fact they're almost the same core
values although the core values of the
air force are integrity service above
self and excellence I think the only one
that MIT doesn't have is the Service
Above Self Service Above Self really
implies perhaps putting your life on the
line for your country in unless you join
the military I think that that's
probably not an expectation that you
would have but your kind of service goes
in a different way to service to country
service to community it's service
service to the nation service to your
family so I mean there is a service
component it's not quite as sharply
drawn as it would be for somebody in a
wheelchair well you know there's some
interesting psychological things
associated with that which I took full
advantage of there's there's a book that
I would recommend
it's called women warriors and basically
what it points out is that throughout
history there have been a few women who
have served in roles like this and that
for the people involved it can be a time
of renewal that there is something
inherently exciting about a woman leader
in a military situation and that you can
get the kind of energy in that situation
that is an order of magnitude larger
than the kind of conventional Ceti and
you know Joan of Arc is the obvious
example but in the British myth there's
somebody called bodacious
you also played that role and in our own
time we had go to my ear and Indira
Gandhi and we had market Thatcher and so
basically what I saw is that there was
an opportunity to energize the
organization and that I was about to
take full advantage of it on their
behalf to make them better
so I emphasized
you know being a woman I I wore you know
flight suits all the time I wore BDUs I
were you know because that that brings
this energy forward in the organization
you know I think it worked I think it
worked I think we had a very very
high-powered intense organization that
was totally focused on the mission
it was totally focused on the core
values I think we just absolutely
improved the organization and and I was
very conscious of them I mean I was
conscious of that opportunity and those
possibilities and I think I think for
the most part we were able to accomplish
that so I think if there's some real
advantages oh no no no no I mean I I
think they say in Washington that if
you're not going to stay for eight years
you should only stay for four I think
there is an expectation that when you
get to the second four-year term that
the people who have positions like mine
will basically retire so that the
president can kind of put in a hole into
them and I think for me it was fine and
and I think MIT was extraordinarily
generous to give me four years leave of
absence there were people down there
from Harvard and Kennedy School the
basically had to resign their positions
in order to be able to stay for four
years I think most of them successfully
went back but there are a lot of
examples of universities not taking
people back after well there's Rush and
what's that guy's name during the
Vietnam War Roscoe Roscoe Walt Rostow
did not get back to Harvard after four
years so I think MIT was extraordinarily
generous
so I think no no it really doesn't
because I always see it as a net plus I
always see it as a net plus I really
believe that because I am a woman that I
have typically been appointed to things
at a younger age than might have
otherwise been the case you know I've
been able to you know in others I I you
know I have a lot more visibility in my
field because I'm a woman now I see the
visibility has to be backed up with
confidence but I think visibility is is
a good thing to have so no I
it's never it's never been an issue for
me I've you know I am Who I am and you
know I get asked to do things and I you
know I accept some and don't accept
others and and I just try to do the best
job so no that's never been an issue so
we just may come from a different time
different time
but I've never been self-conscious about
it
very thankful
Oh
but when you went to the M I don't
airport came back mm-hmm
was there a period of readjustment oh
absolutely yeah I'm still readjusting
the Air Force is tremendously well
organized and I had a staff of roughly
12 to 15 people whose entire job it was
to see that I got to where I needed to
go with what I needed to have and so I
had tremendous staff support and and
they were wonderful people I mean I
thought of them as graduate students
because they were so smart and they were
so productive and you know they were
always writing papers and writing
speeches and and you know doing very
very useful things I missed them all
terribly I mean I just as I say they
really were like my graduate students so
coming back you know I'm setting my own
schedule I'm involved with other
organizations that are not as well
organized as the Air Force I'm vice
president National Academy of
Engineering them on the Governing Board
of the National Research Council and on
several organizations down there and I
sent an email down there the other day
and I said you know I'm really having a
hard time linking into my
responsibilities in your organization I
said you never give me the agenda until
about two weeks before the meeting I
said I never know what's going on I said
you never I said you got to let me know
six weeks in six months in advance when
you're having meetings I said because my
calendar fills up you know I just can't
I it's very hard for me to deal with an
organization that is not what as well
organized just the Air Force you know in
the Air Force know I always knew exactly
what I was doing where I was going while
I was doing it and you know we all had
everything
lined out and now I'm just kind of
floating around trying to fulfill my
responsibilities to a lot of
organizations that are not terribly well
organized and that that's that's
difficult it's difficult for me that's I
think it's much much higher because
basically it's the difference between
one person trying to you know work her
way through a complex organization and
being at the pointy end of a spear
that's like you know a couple thousand
people all pushing in the same direction
so you know I had I had four people
whose job was just to make sure that I
used my time efficiently and I hardly
know the things that didn't happen
because these guys took care of of those
those issues so I was I was just a you
know my time was used a lot more
effectively so that everyday was you
know had the kind of intensity that goes
along with you know using your time
efficiently
no I thought it was more chaotic it was
more chaotic like I was perfectly
relaxed I mean I can give you a little
example when I was in the Air Force I
I advise it to the bicycle to three
thousand miles a year